the latest video of Osama bin Laden's
surface today with the al Qaeda leader
claiming his organization is alive and
well and will continue to target
Americans both abroad and on their own
soil quote we must eliminate the cross
it is alive and well Bob we will blow
you up and they have let me help
no Tripoli reporting for duty sir I put
on 15 pounds of muscle mass I can do 60
push-ups without stopping in 100 if you
give me a 30-second break I can learn
six miles in 42 minutes and I want to
save lives part of me does I could drive
you cause like you're gonna need a
driver to follow a right I think it's
sweet whatever it is well good looks
good no don't tell people you're a
marine ed you know want to compromise
yourself for this office the real heroes
are the ones looking after their fellow
citizens here on the home
- humph right and what I need you to do
Ned's be visually can you do that for me
be vigilant good challenge absolutely
sir
more busy stuff they bought a pocket
igloo some other kind of glue some fuel
and to me
we got the receipt al Qaeda is alive and
well here in America
be vigilant okay I don't know why you
let them chase these pipe dreams there
are terrorists at the airfield there al
Qaeda and they plan to strike today how
Qaeda is alive and well here in the
United States who are you they call us
sundogs
[Music]
you
[Music]
you